[Applaudissements]
sur les carreaux frappa ses gouttes
d'eau la pluie d'hiver sur les Carau
jouette un are
bonjo les doigts posés sur son
banjo un musicien
dormait les doigts posés sur son
BJO un musicien rêvait
rêvait que la
musique qu'il avait
composée partait pour l'Amérique et il
devenait
succès partout là-bas la nuit le jour on
jouait sa
chanson dont tous les mots parlent
d'amour de retour et de pardon
afin afin
peut-être que celle qu'
l'aimait l'entendent enfin peut-être et
lui reviennent à
jamais les
orchres monde entier seste la jouet et
lui dans son rêve il voyait des millions
de couples danser danser sur sa
musique dans un rythme
infernal sur une immense piste sortant
d'une boule de
cristal et c'est alors qu'il a aperçu la
fille qu'il
aimait et c'est alors qu'il
aperçu la
fille la fille qui
riait la pluie d'hiver sur les carreaux
c'est ça c'est goutte
d'eau la pluie d'hiver sur les carreaux
c'est à son a de
banjo les doigts posés sur son
Bano le musicien
pleurait sans voir la porte qui
s'ouvrait sur la fille qui
[Applaudissements]
revenait